[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le grand
studio du figaro on est en direct on est
avec vous ces figues en live et on
attend vos points de vue êtes vous
convaincu et rassuré par les mesures
antiterroristes annoncées par le
gouvernement annonce antiterroriste
annoncées par le gouvernement
cinq jours après l'attentât de
rambouillet on va en débattre avec nos
invités on va revenir également sur une
autre
un autre sujet parce que nos deux
invités que je vais vous présenter tout
de suite temps quand le micro de l'un
d'entre eux sera remis son 2 euros
fervent et deux débatteurs alors on va
leur poser une question à l'heure où
l'union européenne signe son divorce
définitif avec le royaume uni
quel est le vainqueur du bras de fer on
attend vos réponses on attend vos points
de vue et on va les partager avec
christophe de voogd ça il a retrouvé son
unique roman soir christophe historia
est professeur de la spécialiste de
rhétorique politique et professeur à
sciences po merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous christophe ce soir et on va
débattre également avec mathieu soupière
ancien conseiller d'un ministre
socialiste myriam el khomri et expert
auprès de la fondation jean jaurès
c'est la quatorzième loi antiterroriste
qui a été annoncé aujourd'hui le point
fort le point fort est le point phare si
je puis dire c'est tout ce qui est
annoncé autour de la surveillance
préalable en particulier sur internet
sur le numérique avec le recours à la
méthode des algorithmes en clair et bien
si on trouve ici un certain nombre
d'algues au rythme révèle que
vous d'autres personnes fréquentent trop
des contenus sensibles et en particulier
des contenus jihadistes ils pourront
être surveillés et éventuellement
interpellé c'est ce qu'a confirmé ce
midi le ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin
aujourd'hui il faut savoir que lorsque
quelqu'un tape cinq ou six fois une
recherche de vidéos de décapitation par
exemple de dèche sur internet les
services de renseignements ne peuvent
pas le savoir et sucettes personnes
demain nous pourrons connaître cette
information
la dgsi demandera au ministre de
l'intérieur au premier ministre et à la
commission nationale des techniques de
renseignement qui est une autorité
administrative indépendante qui suit
déjà des écoutes téléphoniques
la possibilité de lever l'anonymat de la
personne qui fait ses recherches afin de
pouvoir si le la menace est grave et
avérée suivre et éventuellement
intervenir dans voici donc une
illustration de cette nouvelle méthode
de ce recours qui a été expérimenté ces
dernières années au court d'idées
algorithmes voici ce qu'en pensent l'un
des candidats déclarés à la prochaine
présidentielle le président de la région
haute france xavier bertrand un
algorithme pour pouvoir justement suivre
ce qui se passe notamment sur les
réseaux c'est mieux mais c'est pas à la
hauteur on fait une guerre on fait pas
une guerre si on fait une guerre on se
donne les moyens de réussir moi j'ai
proposé notamment que pour tous les
détenus
enfin tous ceux qui sont condamnés pour
terrorisme pour les détenus on puisse
appliquer une peine de 50 ans parce que
quelqu'un qui commet un acte terroriste
50 ans à 20 ans à 20 ans je ne suis pas
certain qu'à 50 ans tout ce fanatisme
islamique soit sorti de sa tête
al'inverse défenseurs des droits de
l'homme s'inquiète des menaces sur les
libertés individuelles malgré des
protestations dans ce domaine du premier
ministre aujourd'hui jouera je voudrais
savoir quel est le point de vue
justement sur ces sujets de l'ancien
conseiller d'un gouvernement qui a été
confrontée au terrorisme islamiste où
effectivement le parallèle est à mon
avis intéressant parce que le terrorisme
n'a jamais été aussi meurtrier que sous
le quinquennat de françois hollande
alors certain nombre de dispositions ont
été prises à ce moment-là vie avec les
attentats de paris et les atteint et
l'attentât de nice exactement
mais donc le lien direct même tous les
dehors de l'essentiel des victimes du
terrorisme islamique en france depuis 40
ans en fait on l'est on les a
enregistrées sous le quinquennat de
françois hollande
c'était donc une période de deux menaces
très forte et de crispation potentiel de
l'opinion très élevé or à l'époque
l'opinion a été d'un sang froid absolu
ce qui nous a évité une fois que l'état
de l'état de encore une fois l'état
d'urgence avait été décrété
ce qui a malgré tout permis quand même
au pouvoir d'opérer de façon
relativement efficace et d'une
efficacité dont on mesure encore malgré
tout aujourd'hui relativement efficace
quand même à quelques mois d'intervalle
vous avez l'attentât de paris et après
vous avez l'attentât de nice 130 et 80
morts absolument mais j'ai encore une
fois dans cette séquence là des
dispositions ont été prises
l'état d'urgence a été décrété et des
dispositions ont été prises dont
beaucoup ont ensuite été transcrite dans
la loi et d'ailleurs la loi dont on va
reparler en fait celle qui était
présenté aujourd'hui en conseil des
ministres visait aussi à étendre des
dispositifs d'exception de les
transcrire législativement il ya des
choses nouvelles mais il ya aussi tout
simplement des choses sur les avec
lesquels on vit depuis quelques années
donc on a testé manifestement
l'efficacité et qu'on veut l'inscrire
dans la loi de façon pérenne et
j'insiste justement sur cet élément
d'efficacité parce que évidemment c'est
très difficile à entendre quand la
france continue d'être endeuillé quand
des personnes sont touchées
effectivement la policière à rambouillet
mère de deux enfants et c'est
nécessairement l'opinion est frappée
quand ce genre de drames surviennent
encore néanmoins j'insiste sur le fait
qu' il se déjoue bien plus d'attentats
qu'il ne s'en commet et quand même que à
l'exception abbas est sûre en tout cas
je je je ne suis pas un spécialiste de
ces questions mais je m'en tiens à ce
que déclare en particulier les services
du ministère de l'intérieur c'est vrai
que son gros handicap n'a encore été
déjoué il se déjoue trois à quatre
attentats pour un attentat commis un
attentat commis et encore une fois à
l'exception des drames terribles du
bataclan et de nice qui ont fait façon
massive
un coup une quantité de morts
considérable et là nécessairement
l'opinion face à cela et est frappé
bouleversé stomach est aujourd'hui les
attentats et c'est pour ça qu'ils sont
de plus en plus difficile malgré tout à
déjouer reviennent tu as des actes
isolés qui frappent des victimes très
peu nombreuses à chaque fois dans la
fois à nice c'était trois personnes ces
trois personnes de trop c'est un drame
mais c'est ça qui rend en fait la chose
extrêmement complexe je reviens juste et
ensuite je cède la parole sur la notion
de liberté publique et de la déclaration
que faisait la défenseur des droits il
me semble quand même que depuis 2015
nous veillons c'est un parfait mais nous
veillons et quels que soient les
gouvernements à trouver cet équilibre
entre sécurité et liberté
en tout cas il me semble que dans les
discours françois hollande puis si on
faisait référence à cette période
chercher en permanence à a trouvé cette
ligne de crête dans un contexte
extrêmement compliqué il s'est passé
quelque chose depuis qui n'a rien à voir
avec le terrorisme qui a à voir avec le
co lead depuis un an et demi que nous
vivons avec cette crise sanitaire
nous avons encore en fait fait évoluer
notre législation et nous avons encore
amputée nos libertés individuelles et en
fait tout le débat face aux menaces
quiconque on mesure aujourd'hui que ce
soit le terrorisme où que ce soit une
pandémie
tout le débat quand même et peut-être
d'ailleurs cela alimentera t-il le débat
de la présidentielle dans quelques mois
tout le débat c'est qu'elle est l'
équilibre qu'on se donne dans une
démocratie entre la problématique de
sécurité et la problématique de liberté
individuelle
christophe oui je suis pas persuadé que
le calcule combien d'attentats évité par
rapport à combien d'attentats qui ont
lieu soit le bon c'est comme si on
disait pour des centrales nucléaires
boye en a qu'une qui a explosé
finalement il ya dortmund en a 40
je crois que ce serait un calcul qui
serait un peu surprenant ce qui m'étonne
toujours là dans vos choix libéral je
suivais donc je suis très sensible
peut-être encore plus que la gauche
historiquement à la question des droits
de l'homme et et en particulier des
libertés publiques qui ce que votre
engagement que je ne vais pas rappeler à
la fondapol rappelle anac
votre donc je suis votre engagement nous
sommes les partisans les plus jeunes
ouverte et surtout la philosophie
d'alexis de tocqueville voilà elle s'est
donc nous sommes les partisans de la
liberté alors que la gauche est comme
vous le savez partisane de l'égalité
donc la question est on y est très
sensible
mais le problème de cette loi c'est le
14e mois seulement donc le one de ses
toiles il est triple d'une part je vous
rappelle que c'est à chaque fois un
drame une loi tant qu'on parle n'a pas
pâli la faire leur alyah les loisirs
sont défendus 1 502 forme de affaire
halimi c'est aussi une loi qui va venir
donc c'est toujours un drame une loi et
cela quand même pose un problème
d'autant qu emmanuel macron avait bien
dit que ce serait justement pas sa
politique c'est dans son programme
deuxièmement c'est le problème toujours
en france qui n'est pas le problème du
nombre de lois ça se saurait on est les
champions du monde
c'est le problème de leur application
david lisnard le rappelait ce matin
surtout dans une jarre et le maire de
cannes sur tous les sujets c'est vos
confrères de lci sur tous les sujets
nous avons un problème d'application de
la loi c'est bien avec la faire
justement la limite c'est un problème
d'application de la loi
et puis il remarque de fonds et moi qui
m'inquiète c'est cette tendance toujours
à très profond et qui peut-être
caractérise le maquereau nisme c'est à
dire à ne pas traiter le sujet et la
personne concernée mais entre était un
autre sujet est traité l'ensemble de la
population au lieu de concentrer son
action sur le sujet dans cette affaire
le sujet de ce garçon après tant
d'autres qui a commis l'attentât
après plusieurs autres de suite est ce
que c'est le sujet de la consultation
des sites jihadistes ou est ce que c'est
le sujet du réfugié ou du séjour non
autorisée en france et ça c'est très
intéressant c'est que vous comme le
gouvernement vous fait une diversion
rhétorique c'est à dire que le problème
c'est devait-il être en france avant
même de savoir quel réseau est il allé
consulter je vous rappelle quand même
que tous les derniers attentats sont des
attentats de réfugiés de gens en
situation irrégulière donc c'est une
chose encore une fois vous pouvez pas
dire oui mais tant pis non ces gens là
devraient in the first place comme
disent nos amis anglais dont on va
bientôt parler n'aurait pas dû
là à ce moment et moi ce qui m'inquiète
beaucoup en tant que libéral c'est que
donc on a une tendance à faire des lois
générales
c'est aussi vous avez tout à fait bien
rappeler sur le co lead 1
c'est à dire vous rentrez tous à la
maison vous restez chez vous et on isole
pas les malades par exemple cette espèce
de déviation du sujet et cela me
préoccupe beaucoup parce que du coup on
sacrifie les libertés tout le monde
alors qu'on devrait en prendre aux
libertés de quelques-uns ont réduit les
libertés on s'attaque pas au problème
c'est ce que dit christophe de vagues
avec notre questions qu'il soulève le
fait le premier ministre a été interrogé
sur sa ce midi au monde annonce de cette
loi sur la question justement de lien
entre l'immigration et le terrorisme ce
qui est intéressant c'est que quand le
premier ministre a été interrogée sur
cette question notre le confrère qui lui
a posé la question à site emmanuel
macron qui dit qu'on ne pouvait pas
s'empêcher de faire le lien dans
certains cas et c'était des propos que
emmanuel macron avait tenus au figaro et
de ce point de vue là
jean castex a dit tout à l'heure que il
était indéniable que certains auteurs de
faits terroristes étaient démunis et des
immigrés et les immigrés clandestins
sans papiers et mais lui il refuse de
faire de la lutte il refuse en tout cas
il dit nous devons lutter contre
l'immigration irrégulière mais ne pas
confondre la politique contre le
terrorisme et contre l'immigration
irrégulière c'est un problème
d'efficacité c'est toujours de tabou de
s'attaquer finalement au lien entre
l'immigration et les terroristes non je
crois pas en fait c'est le tropisme de
quelqu'un de quelques-uns pardon mais je
crois pas que ce soit tabou pour
beaucoup d'autres en réalité levage aux
jeux vous appelez le tropisme mathieu
sait le faire le lien non non non non en
l'occurrence c'est le lien qui serait
faire que jeu quand même pour nuancer ce
que dit christophe première éléments si
le le le
comment le meurtrier de la semaine
dernière pouvait tout à fait être là où
ils étaient ils avaient été régularisées
non mais depuis il était resté dix ans
certes mais je pars non mais si on vous
entend pas permis d'aller chez gitana ok
donc non il devait pas être là soyons là
ok si on est prêt si encore une fois si
on est prêt si il n'était plus
clandestins au moment où il a ils
avaient été régularisées pardonnez moi
c'est à dire que et encore une fois je
ne fais pas l'apologie d'une
régularisation massive et systématique
celle installée cet assaut fils je ne
dis pas cela en attendant il se trouve
que les autorités françaises l'avaient
régularisés j'imagine avec un certain
nombre d'éléments pour le faire et bien
c'est là qu'on n'est pas d'accord alors
mais avait-elle autoritaire mais c'est
encore une fois ils n'étaient pas
clandestins deuxième dimension jeu ça a
été beaucoup dit quand même au cours de
ces derniers jours
oui il est vrai que un certain nombre
d'attentats parmi les plus récemment
commis sont le fait de deux migrants
illégaux mais 80% des attentats en
france et l'essentiel des victimes ont
été faites dans le cadre de l'attentât
commis par des français
ah parce qu'il aurait adoré alors là il
faut vraiment s'arrêter tout de suite
c'est parce que ce jeu l'entente
j'entends cette confusion sur tous les
plateaux immigrés pour vous ça veut dire
étrangers je je je cours beaucoup diront
vous opposer au fait qu'on parle de
l'immigration vous dites français par
opposition oui français c'est la
nationale
oui mais c'est pas une nationalité
immigrés ça veut pas dire étrangers
nommés en l'occurrence les derniers
attentats pardon de direction c'est que
c'était des français d'origine immigrée
qui avait commis la plupart du temps des
attentats la quasi-totalité champagne
offert coin de la rue du barry exemple
mais met ainsi un tiers de la population
française aujourd'hui est d'origine
immigrée première génération ou deuxième
set mais est ce que je n'avais vous ne
pouvez pas dire immigrés ou français ces
français ou étrangers on est d'accord
immigrés ou français ça n'a pas de sens
elle vous parle immigrés clandestins
non mais et alors je fais un jeu nous
nous enfermons pas non mais c'est
important parce que c'est comme ça qu'on
force les statistiques
d'accord c'est à dire que moi je suis un
immigré de la deuxième génération oui
mais je suis français né en france de
parents français
oui donc donc quand vous pas dit mais
donc j'ai ça n'a aucun sens mais encore
une fois le nom je reviens sur le fait
qu' aujourd'hui en france et c'est
d'ailleurs un vrai problème des
attentats sont commis par des français
deux des français les français d'origine
immigrée mais derrière c'est du message
mais pas nécessairement de la première
génération nan nan c'est là qu'on peut
abattre côté prenait encore une fois
cette mais c'est un vrai débat le fait
que des français peu importe leurs
origines des français en france installé
en france depuis longtemps commettent
des attentats de cette nature d'être
effectivement la menace est entre
guillemets intérieur et elle n'est pas
donc le simple fait d'immigrés
clandestins
voilà donc jeu c'était juste pour
remettre ça dès caire ensuite encore une
fois le lien entre l'immigration et
l'immigration clandestine et le
terrorisme n'est pas établi de façon
systématique au point que cela
justifierait de prendre des dispositions
des politiques publiques qui soient
adaptées à cette situation sans espoir
que l'allemagne a ouvert ses frontières
en 2016 au moment de la vague migratoire
terrible en gala merkel a décidé que
l'allemagne allait à aller accueillir un
million de migrants
le terrorisme n'a pas flambé colonnes
les attaques et attentats du marché mais
remettons ça remettons ça à l'échelle de
ce qu'a été la vague migratoire
on ne peut pas dire vague migratoire
égale flambée du terrorisme le
terrorisme existe depuis toujours
partout et ça n'a rien à voir avec des
entrées massives ou moins massive
il n'y a pas d'arrière garde ans mathieu
mais là je vous pose une question
puisque ça encore en y fait référence et
c'est quelque chose que vous avez suivi
de près mais l'attentât de l'attentât d'
les attentats de paris
parmi eux a été quand même commandité
depuis l'étranger
et parmi les auteurs et parmi les
organisateurs il y à des personnes qui
on veut profiter de la crise migratoire
de 2015 qui sont arrivées de grèce et
qui sont arrivés en france à la faveur
du du mouvement je ne pouvons l'accepter
de ne compter que dorian a marqué je ne
conteste pas du tout que ça a été le cas
mais encore une fois le signe d'égalité
entre migration et terrorisme ne
correspond pas avec les bars de ça moi
je vous propose une solution pour vous
réconcilier je crois que c'est vraiment
audio le piège des mots quand on dit le
lien vous entendez causalité ou égalité
moi je dis précise simplement conditions
il y a un lien quand on parle
corrélation en statistiques
ce n'est pas forcément une causalité ait
eu aucun la causalité par exemple
peut-être ailleurs très bien mais pour
l'exemple dans l'occurrence elle
pourrait être dans l'islamisme la vraie
causalité suivons là dessus dans aucun
représentant des forces de l'ordre ne
considère aujourd'hui qu'il y aurait une
efficacité en matière de lutte contre le
terrorisme a fermé les frontières
la menace terroriste même avec des
frontières fermées resterait élevé oui
c'est comme ça c'est comme pour le coc
vide
le terrorisme n'a pas de visa comme le
virus n'a pas de passeport non mais
enfin la zep ardeurs mais encore une
fois non salées les services de
renseignements je mangeais pas du tout
le même seco que vous allez faire c'est
de renseignement estime que c'est pas
réponse ça n'est pas du tout la
fermeture des deux candidats ce que
cette coopération entre les pays irait
bien sûr mais ils disent que ce n'est
pas suffisant on est bien d'accord mais
encore une fois gens qu'on peut se
mettre d'accord moi je ne fais pas c'est
qu'ils nous disent c'est qu'ils se
plient migration tireur et services de
renseignement disent que la fermeture
des frontières n'est pas suffisante
c'est un gars tellement c'est comme pour
le vide d'ailleurs un pour les mêmes
raisons donc moi qui suis de le pen le
seul à ces tables qui sud le seul
immigré la deuxième génération je suis
donc bien placé pour vous dire qu'il y a
pas identité n'est égalité entre les
deux
bien d'accord et que pour moi la vraie
causalité c'est l'islamisme
on est bien d'accord la vraie oui bon
cela dit l'immigration on l'a vu sur des
cas très concrets on le voit avec le cas
de tous de ces réfugiés de ces
clandestins ou de s'est régularisée cas
pour me retirer pas l'idée que s'ils
étaient partis du territoire il ya dix
ans il n'aurait pas été là avant-hier je
ne veux pas mais vous pouvez me prouver
donc cette idée là c'est que nous devons
méfier de ces raccourcis on est bien
d'accord dans les deux sens c'est-à-dire
dire ça n'a rien à voir qui est quand
même la réaction dominante
médiatico-politique non non non pas dire
son nom et depuis une semaine on ne
parle de ça oui le puits ne fait une
semaine on ne parle que de ça une
semaine les moyens de consommer du lien
de causalité nom de lien alors justement
encore une fois qu'on dise moi je dis
conditions de cette techno conditions
j'en ai fait ça n'est pas une causalité
direct je crains toujours beaucoup ne
prennent pas de subtilités de à tout cas
le gouvernement n'est pas d'accord avec
lui même c'est surtout ça qui est
ennuyeux
qu'est ce que vous entendez le premier
ministre a dit donc à le premier
ministre a dit nous devons lutter contre
l'immigration irrégulière et nous devons
lutter contre l'immigration et le
terrorisme mais il ne faut pas confondre
la politique contre le terrorisme et
contre l'immigration irrégulière c'est
un problème d'efficacité
il est assez d'accord avec vous mais le
président avait parlé un peu
différemment au figaro bruno le maire a
parlé un peu différemment
il ya quelques jours à la télévision il
voudrait là aussi qu'il y ait la guerre
nous contredira pas un peu plus de
cohérence dans la tribune
gouvernementale je vais gouvernementale
accordée lors néanmoins d'être face à un
phénomène d'une complexité inouïe est
par ailleurs en matière de lutte contre
l'immigration clandestine
je ne connais pas un gouvernement qui
n'est pas tenté de faire le maximum
alors certains d'eux explique
aujourd'hui que en étant aux affaires
demain il réglerait le problème
certains mêmes qui par ailleurs ont pu
être aux affaires il n'y a pas si
longtemps ils n'ont pas réglé le
problème
on est face à un phénomène d'une
complexité inouïe
voilà oui j'avais personne ne veut pas
dire enfin à partir de rien le
terroriste est une fatalité y en a
toujours eu partout il ya des pays qui
ont su s'en débarrasser
c'est passionnant vous de vous entendre
débattre jeu
on a passé d'ailleurs le temps imparti
pour cette partie du débat mais c'est
très intéressant d'avoir des points de
vue qui sont très très opposés sur ce
débat qui est sensible tant même le
nouveau projet de loi antiterroriste est
il pertinent c'est la question qu'on
vous pose sur twitter rock vous ne dites
il faut du courage politique et mettre
en place une déchéance de nationalité
alors sur ça je pense que vous n'êtes
pas d'accord mathieu mais on rappelle
quand même que ça a été quelque chose
qui avait été soulevée déjà après les
attentats de paris par françois hollande
sur france info que le l'opinion était
quasi unanimement favorable à cette
disposition et françois hollande s'est
pris les pieds dans le tapis
la gauche a été contré ces essais les
frondeurs qu'on gagne absolument au
monde a perdu d'ailleurs dans cette
affaire on avance que tout le monde a
perdu
on applique même pas les lois qui sont
en vigueur nous dit françoise on devrait
peut-être interdire le terrorisme
finalement dit ironiquement yoyo quoi
qu'il en soit la confiance envers les
politiques est interdit un drôle c'est
interdit vegas quoi qu'il en soit la
confiance envers les politiques est
sérieusement entamée nous dit julien est
le propre du terroriste et de violer la
loi
ce n'est pas une phrase sur le code
pénal qui va les arrêter nous dit cet
autre internaute qui se fait appeler
patriotique geovanni un drame une loi
génial c'est une véritable approche là
aussi on en eut en d'antan et on devine
ligne l'ironie nathan 770 promulgué une
énième loi à la noix n'est qu'une
manoeuvre politique destinée à apaiser
l'opinion mais c'est du néant
alors quand même pour sur ce plan là un
à temps il faut rappeler que le
gouvernement est en tout cas a insisté
sur le fait et le premier ministre a
insisté sur le fait que cette loi était
déjà en discussion depuis plusieurs mois
et c'est une réactualisation d'une loi
qui a été adopté en octobre 2017 qui
s'appelle la loi sylt sécurité
intérieure et lutte contre le terrorisme
l'occurrence darmanin n'a pas fait du
sarkozy
un fait divers une loi ou une
disposition quand même il faut plus
d'argent d'agents de terrain des vrais
nous dit tony je rappelle donc on va
regarder la réponse à la question
composé sur twitter le nouveau projet de
loi antiterroriste est il pertinent et
vous répondez non à 69 % c'est votre
avis pareil parce que moi je réponds non
mais pas 69% pour ça pour vous il est
pertinent
actuellement alors je suis désolé mais
je pense qu'il est beaucoup trop tôt
pour répondre à cette question car à
l'aune des résultats qu'on aura
éventuellement obtenu avec l'application
de cette loi on verra si elle était
pertinente et efficace à la jeu
politique se juge à ses fruits
absolument c'est en l'occurrence encore
une fois je maintiens que en matière de
lutte contre le terrorisme
si nous étions si nous étions aussi
inefficace que cela nous aurions
malheureusement à à pleurer bien
davantage d'attentats mais cet argument
n'a pas consolé christophe mais on leur
a tout à l'heure ça vous a peut-être
échappé mais le parlement européen va
entériner l'accord conclu le 27 décembre
dernier entre l'union européenne et la
grande-bretagne vote qui a une très
large majorité alors les britanniques et
boris johnson savoureux l'événement
voici ce que leur répond le secrétaire
d'état aux affaires européennes clément
bonne
d'abord cet accord je le répète c'est un
bon accord parce qu'il à préserver nos
intérêts français et européens sur la
pêche en particulier sur la concurrence
entre secteurs économiques c'est donnant
donnant on peut pas on cherche une
coopération on a un bon accord il faut
que chacun se respecte ses engagements
sinon nous serons aussi brutaux et un
fils il que nécessaire comme partenaire
alors clément bonne promet d'être
brutale et si les britanniques ne
respectent pas leurs engagements vous y
croyez sur d'abord sur l'ensemble je
crois qu'il faut arrêter de pleurer ce
qui est intéressant dans cette affaire
c'est que contrairement à ce qu'on dit
partout c'est en angleterre
johnson est très attaquée par les plus
extrémistes de son côté comme faraj un
débreak sitter ardeur à dire à qui
trouvent que il a trop lâché à l'europe
seul dominique kumming sousse absolument
savoir compter et en europe
l'europe est critiquée pour pour avoir
trop la chaîne britannique alors en
général vous avez d'expérience et là je
pense qu'on sera d'accord
quand un résultat écrite et qui des deux
côtés c'est plutôt bon signe
1 ça veut dire que quand on a trouvé un
bon compromis et deuxièmement je veux
dire quand même une chose et je le dis
vraiment sincèrement parce que j'ai eu
une expérience je crois que comme
mathieu on a une expérience européenne
gta iv conseil des ministres européens à
bruxelles
et franchement les anglais se sont de
redoutables négociateurs je voulais que
je vous les recommande pas si vous
voulez ce que je vais dire est ce sont
des gens qui ne lâche rien ce sont les
meilleurs négociateurs d'europe et en
plus ils ont une chance énorme c'est que
tout le monde et gossier dans leur
langue
autrement dit ils commencent à 1 0 le
match de foot voyez à quoi je fais
allusion est donc pas la subir vide
entre non mais à quelque chose qui se
passe ce soir
donc si vous voulez le vraiment ils
partent avec un gros avantage est une
mais ce sont des gens terrifiant et les
que j'adore un parieur mais ils sont
terrifiés en négociation donc vraiment
il faut quand même rendre hommage à
monsieur barnier et aux européens qui
n'ont pas lâché qui se soit pas divisé
pendant quatre ans des preuves pour
arriver à arracher le morceau
moi je alors pardonnez moi je pense que
vous allez d'accord mathieu et donc je
veux faire l'objection mais c'est une
objection
si on a manqué c'est une objection serre
que donc depuis le début on dit alors là
franchement c'est formidable les
européens ont été tous ensemble c'est
une belle performance etc
mais en fait les britanniques
les britanniques ont gagné la manche
donc qu'est-ce qu'ils regagnaient les
britannique en gagne à longchamp dit on
avait dit ça se passera mal ce sera
l'apocalypse et finalement ça se passe
bien je regarde sur la vaccination
aujourd'hui la moitié de la population
britannique qui n'a pas grande bretagne
qui n'a pas eu à suivre le protocole et
les process de négociations qui ont été
suivis par l'union européenne la moitié
de la population britannique a reçu une
première dose c'est 24% dans l'union
européenne
c'est plus de la moitié j'ose même pas
pardonné des chiffres des français pour
sa part la haye ce qu'est ce que vous
croyez à l'ordre il ya deux choses là
dedans est ce que vous croyez que les
anglais vaccine si bien à cause du bric
six mois là je vois c'est un peu comme
je ferai mon mathieu dire to care je
vois pas le rapport
c'est à dire que mettre dans le cadre de
l'europe un pays aurait et les anglais
seraient arrêtés dans l'europe on
avisera quand même fait cavalier seul
oui ce que je veux dire que rien
n'obligeait celle que je vous laisse je
vous rappelle qu'il n'y a pas de nos
politiques de santé communautaire
autrement dit c'est un acte volontaire
on a saisi on a suivi une politique on
n'a pas de politique de santé
communautaire mais dans cette dans la
cette affaire on a suivi on a fait comme
s'il y en avait une
et même là où lui et emmanuel macron
alors appelons appelons un chat un chat
est ce que je veux dire c'est quand même
emmanuel macron et madame merkel qui
l'ont voulu
n'oubliez pas non plus que si nous
manque 300 millions de doses
c'est grâce à qui si j'ose dire c'est la
france qui a demandé qu'on mette 300
millions de doses de côté au cas où
sanofi un jour découvrir et un vaccin
bon donc il faut quand même ramené un
petit peu en france on a quand même
cette légère tendance 1 à toujours dire
quand on a une petite faiblesse c'est la
faute à bruxelles bon pour le break si
tu mènes répondait aux critiques je vous
hais il y avait deux par six ans à 2
europe et deux européens oui 5-2
européiste non non pas du tout autre
pays parce que parce que l'europe a mal
joué ils avec art est d'abord laver car
exister enfin bon peu importe mais en
tout cas
rappelons quand même les responsabilités
de chacun parce qu'on a un peu tendance
à s'en dédouaner
et puis je pense que les anglais n'ont
pas eu tout ce qu'il voulait regardez
bien l'accord de bruxelles sur l'irlande
du nord ils sont pas du tout contents
mais vraiment pas du tout sous les
pêcheries sur la pêche
il aurait vraiment voulu se garder leurs
poissons d'ailleurs ça va être le vrai
sujet et je vous garantis déjà que
l'europe perd à ça comme ça que ça va se
régler
mais l'europe ira bon mais les les
anglais n'ont pas obtenu et air surtout
il voulait avoir le beurre et l'argent
du beurre grosso modo 1
ils ne l'ont pas eu regardez là tu veux
demander au journal citi s'ils sont
contents mathieu ils ne l'ont pas eu
ils ne l'ont pas eu mais est-ce que
c'est à dire qu'ils ne l'auront pas tel
que c'est parti
le en tout cas à ce stade j'ai pas envie
de chipoter sur en accord avec beaucoup
des choses qui ont été dites par
christophe dirait un peu comme chez
jacques martin tout le monde a gagné
d'abord en le tout simplement le break
site a eu lieu quand il ya cinq ans le
référendum a donné le break site gagnant
1 c'était un cataclysme et de on n'était
pas sûr que le processus aille jusqu'au
bout
souvenons nous qu'en 2005 sur un autre
type de sujet qui avait à voir avec
l'europe il ya eu un référendum chez
nous dont objectivement le résultat n'a
pas été suivie d'effet donc là il ya eu
une souveraineté populaire qui en
angleterre s'est exprimé et qui a été
respectée alors même que le contexte
était extrêmement difficile et que la
sphère était elle-même très complexe à
mener
on est allé au bout le bric site a eu
lieu donc le plus cher est que le peuple
anglais peu de ce point de vue là en
fait s'estimer satisfait mais en face
encore une fois au moment où ça s'est
passé
on sortait par ailleurs de la crise de
l'euro on sortait du grec site de la
potentielle sortie du sud de l'europe
par la grèce
on craignait un effet domino et on
craignait que l'europe se désagrège
elle ne s'est pas désagréger elle a tenu
alors ok on peut discuter
tout ne va pas bien 100% des députés
européens n'ont pas voté mais la quasi
totalité des députés ont voté à la fin
il ya un accord sur lequel tout le monde
semble à peu près se retrouver et je
suis d'accord avec christophe pardon
mais en matière de stratégie vaccinale
l'europe n'a sans doute pas été le
continent le plus efficace c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire
mais encore une fois en faisant on
on valoir entre ses membres un principe
de solidarité qui ensuite très
concrètement n'est pas si facile que ça
à faire vivre encore une fois on fait on
monte une une opération politique une
construction politique à 27
évidemment quand on est 27 autour de la
table peut-être que ça prend 27 fois
plus de temps de se mettre d'accord que
quand on est tout seul
voilà ça c'est c'est là qu'on la
complexité de la construction européenne
mais néanmoins encore une fois l'europe
n'a pas explosé et quant aux
conséquences et de la victoire on peut
éventuellement la mesure et à moyen ou à
long terme
à court terme j'estime que personne n'a
perdu on verra à moyen terme ce qui se
passe encore une fois personne n'a
intérêt à ce qu'il y ait un vainqueur et
un perdant
même si l'europe a tenu à à faire voter
dans la résolution l'idée que
l'angleterre avait commis une erreur
historique c'est assez étrange mais dans
le préambule il est quand même
mentionner les volets c'est pour eux je
dirais la galerie sas et ouais mais je
suis quand même étonné en fait que
l'europe se soit laissé aller
c'est pour eux dans en fait le corps
quand vous avez parlé du chiffon rouge
des dominos et tout ça l'europe
évidemment a essayé de dissuader tous
les zones et donc on a on a on en a
vraiment fait des tonnes
mais jusqu'à présent et si on est
vraiment anti ben brik sitter comme je
le suis il faut quand même savoir que
c'est l'angleterre qui a payé quand même
très cher en récession en
désinvestissement on nous conseille par
exemple la première place européenne ça
je suis bien placé pour le savoir
désormais en matière financière ces
amsterdam londres a perdu quand même une
place qu'elle sait la maison parce que
c'est un retour de l'histoire vous avez
qu'amsterdam était avant longtemps avait
remplacé amsterdam et hop c'est reparti
à amsterdam et des néerlandais qui était
très très très très et craignait
beaucoup le bric site du coup sont un
petit peu plus contenu un peu content
parce qu'ils ont récupéré beaucoup
beaucoup de sièges sociaux
non mais si vous voulez et je ferai
juste laminé sur la vaccination
soyons bien clairs l'europe aurait pu
faire beaucoup mieux
la question est est ce que il ya
toujours ce sophisme sous-entendus est
ce que la france en l'europe aurait fait
mieux
c'est ça la vraie question est sans
valeur et amis qu'on fait ce calcul la
la grippe pour l'instant mais parce
qu'il était seul ou est ce parce qu'ils
étaient britanniques parce que les
français je pose simplement la question
si nous avions agi seul
nous est ce que nous ne serions pas en
train
d'attendre le vaccin sanofi mais qu'est
ce que je vois je pose cette question
alors l'objection par rapport à ça je
suis désolé on essaie l'horreur du temps
de temps imparti donc vous allez devoir
faire une réponse brève mais mon cher
christophe mais les britanniques se sont
appuyés notamment pour leurs stratégies
vaccinales sur une pme française basée à
saint nazaire que la france n'a pas
voulu gagne jamais d'accord donc donc c
est ce que c'est la faute à l'europe ça
non mais dans le côté est ce que les
français n'auraient pas pu utiliser des
ressources qui leur étaient propres
nous sommes donc d'accord mais bien un
problème français pas forcément pas
forcément puisque vous partez du fait
que si la france a été agit en tout cas
sans l'europe ou dit agir seul risque
d'une autre question mais elle aurait
elle aurait perdu
elle aurait été perdante pas forcément
c'est là mais pourquoi est-ce qu en quoi
la france apparaît en quel rapport entre
l'europe et le fait que la france n'ait
pas écouté ces pme ça c'est un autre
problème
s'il a répondu à votre première je vous
dis nous serions en train d'abandonner
sanofi mais vous avez gagné parce que
vous êtes vous êtes transformés en la
personne qui pose des questions et moi
qui devrait donner des réponses qui
donnait que c'est bien au dessus des
cages de laquelle rôle des intervenants
qui étaient sur ce plateau et de vous
aussi chers internautes je donne vos
vos commentaires guillaume qui pensent
comme sans doute christophe en
particulier et sans doute mathieu allait
demander un pêcheur agriculteurs
commerçants anglais s'il est satisfait
du bric site il dira non henry il est
trop tôt pour le dire on n'a pas de
recul les côtés positifs nous serviront
peut-être pour améliorer nos
dysfonctionnements kriss kross
bravo les breaks sitter ça permet au
british de limiter l'immigration de
masse
on fera mieux de réformer l'europe
plutôt que de la détruire nous dit leo
et véronique ont ils un jour était dans
l'union européenne
à bien des égards ils s'en sont servi et
je pense que ça ça fera une sur ce
plateau merci beaucoup
les britanniques quand il remportait le
pari du bric site c'était la question
quand vous posez sur twitter et je vais
j'avais répondu oui à 60 %
j'ai juste une dernière question même si
on est en dehors du temps imparti
précisément quel est votre pronostic
pour ce soir passagers je ne le fais
plus aucun pronostic ni en football ni
en politique ni en médecine êtes comme
le brassard à vous je ne fais pas de
pronostics quand il ya un match entre le
qatar et les émirats
je laisse donc la partie la
responsabilité des maps pour seulement
aux personnes qui ont été qui sont
intervenus sur ce plateau et qui
n'engagent qu'elles-mêmes bien entendu
mais merci d'avoir répondu avec
franchise
on se retrouve très vite et on connaîtra
le résultat du match de ce soir
quand on se retrouvera demain pour
débattre entre lucile schmid et vincent
trémolet de villers à très vite sur fear
alive
[Musique]